le moins qu'on puisse dire c'est que la
tendance n'est pas au claquage de
portièr l'industrie de l'auto n'a pas
prévu de rouler au pas on n jamais vendu
autant de SUV qu'aujourd'hui et même
s'il faut 10 tonnes de pétrole rien que
pour construire une voiture que c'est un
des plus gros facteurs d'émission de gaz
à effet de ser de notre pays que les
particules fines donnent des cancers du
poumon à nos enfants leur vente explose
explose littéralement même le président
de la République il y a quelques jours
dans un de ses discours officiels et
policiés nous glissaient pourtant en
nous les français on a adore la bagnole
alors j'ai repensé à tous ces souvenirs
construits dans mon technococon aux
confessions sur le volant aux copilotes
monomaniaque de Dalida aux enguelades
avec mon frère pour savoir qui montera
devant au sandwich triangle les plus
chers et les moins bons de France sur
les air d'autoroute au jambangourdi à la
légère nausée et au retour de nuit c'est
vrai qu'on y est bien dans notre
technococon qu'on croit y être bien
quand on oublie que les paysages qui
glissent à la fenêtre disparaissent pour
de vrai à mesure des kilomètres qu'on
croit y être bien jusqu'à ce qu'on se
prenne le mur de la catastrophe
climatique en plein pare-brise l'impact
sans airbag ni ceinture de sécurité vers
lequel l'industrie automobile nous
projette à vive allure alors la vraie
question et peut-être la seule qui
devrait nous obséder c'est de savoir si
la voiture roule encore pour nous ou
bien si c'est nous qui roulons pour que
son industrie continue à faire du profit
le philosophe Jacques Hul nous alertait
déjà sur le lien de domination entre
l'homme et l'outil il y a ce point de
bascule au-delà duquel le rapport
s'inverse on devient à son service plus
que l'inverse en 1973 déjà Ivan ilich
faisait le calcul un Américain moyen
consacre 1600 he par an à sa voiture
soit 4 heur par jour il y a le temps en
voiture certes mais à celui-ci s'ajoute
le temps de travail pour la payer puis
payer l'essence les payages l'assurance
les impôts et les réparations pour tout
ce temps donné l'Américain moyen
parcourt une distance de 10000 km il
avance donc à 6 km/h c'est à peine plus
qu'une marche rapide je rentre d'un
weekend de mobilisation contre
l'autoroute a69 entre castre et Toulouse
pour gagner 17 minutes des centaines
d'arbres autant d'hectares de terre
cultivable et des gens expropriés de
leur maison sur le tracé entre garder
des champs pour se nourrir et agrandir
les routes pour aller plus vite au
supermarché ils ont choisi dans une
tribune plus de 1500 scientifiques du JC
et du CNRS nous alertaient chaque mètre
carré de terre que l'on artificialise
participe à compromettre les conditions
de vie sur Terre pourtant d'ici à 2050
il y aura plus de 25 millions de
kilomètres de route supplémentaires soit
600 fois le tour de la terre on roule à
plus de 110 km/h vers une 6è extinction
de masse à coup de pelleteuse où sommes
en train de manger le monde et de couler
la vie sous du bitume pour gagner
quelques minutes de trajet ils accélère
notre chute alors on continuera avec
abnégation à ralentir leur monde contre
leur payage à leur faire payer
l'enlaidissement du monde qui nous
impose face à leur couloir de bitum ont
choisi des chemins de traverse face à la
honteuse direction du monde qui nous
disent inévitable on construit une autre
route venez la voie bas